is there something you can comment on
possible ideas like so first of all like
i mean uh
uh like you could use nuclear so nuclear
pulse propulsion
yeah so that's i mean you've probably
heard of project orion which um
was the
freeman dyson uh and
some of his collaborators
had a scheme to um
to power a large space vehicle by
detonating atomic bombs behind it
and so one of the other people who was
working at blue operations during this
time was george dyson the son of freeman
and so we knew all about
project orion and he found an old
film that they'd shot on a beach in la
jolla of a prototype of this that was
powered by
like uh lumps of c4
so that was an idea but for private
company obtaining a large number of
atomic bombs was probably out of scope
so
there's more of a theoretical
thing there's a
conceptually similar
approach using lasers that
that freeman worked on
with arthur kantrowitz and some others
where you take a pulse blazer
and you fire it at a vehicle that has a
block of ice on the back
and the pulse hits the
ice and
flashes off a layer of steam that
becomes plasma
and plasma is opaque because it conducts
and so being opaque it then absorbs all
of the
energy from the laser pulse and gets
really hot
and just pushes on the back of the the
block of ice
and then you wait a moment for that to
dissipate and then you do it again
so it would just kind of
vibrate its way
like it sounds really violent but
freeman said that if you were wearing
like rubber soled tennis shoes standing
in this vehicle you would just feel a
mild
vibration
so there your source of energy is on the
ground and you're getting higher
specific impulse than you could get by
burning chemicals
jordan care and others worked on another
laser system
the late dr jordan care
that just would heat up a heat exchanger
by
converging many converging solid-state
lasers from the ground
and kevin parkin
works on a similar scheme that just uses
uh microwaves
to do that
we looked at
tall towers
i spent a while looking kind of semi
seriously at giant bullwhips
um with a bullet
just a whip just uh
you have them here in texas right
yeah i understand
but how does that have to do with
propulsion if you think about it a whip
is an incredibly simple
primitive object
that can break the speed of sound
so it's unbelievable in a way that for
thousands of years
people with no technology
have been able to
to accelerate objects
through the speed of sound
just through an architectural trick
just just you know just the physics of a
moving bend of material in a medium
can do this so
[Music]
so that's the thing i still think about
from time to time you can use the same
physics to make freestanding loops of
chain or
or other flexible materials
that just kind of stand up under their
own
[Music]
physics
i mean it's kind of awesome
to imagine so imagine using the same
kind of physics of a whip
but have
at the end of it
a spaceship yeah
that would detach
at the moment of maximum
velocity
why
why not
why wouldn't that so part of
my motivation in studying that was to
ask that that question it was it was
more uh almost a
symbolic way of saying
look
there's all kinds of physics we haven't
explored yet
that it's no more crazy
than the idea of chemical rockets
um
it's just that more money's gone into
chemical rockets right
you